hey everybody what's going on I'm here
with TJ Miller star Silicon Valley and
big hero 6 that's right say hi to twitch
TJ hi rich
TJ today we're gonna play sports friends
are you a competitive kind of person or
no no but I'm big on titles that say
exactly what they are perfect words
friends is all about friends they like
sports
that's right exactly we're gonna play
this game called in sports Ren's called
super pole riders now do you want to you
want to go throughout a player do you
just want me to kind of tell you what a
muddle through it this is my first time
holding a consult so I think we can just
go for it all right let's just go for it
all right perfect
we'll play yeah so move move this to the
left there you go and then just press
the X button all right awesome choose
your guy a tightwad stone cold death
grip for a guy named adventurous yeah oh
these are the tech adventurous homes
generous I want to be generous generous
alright I'll be is a fedora because he
wants everybody to be happy about head
where I'm gonna go open-minded bear
because I kind of my neighbor also has
cutoff t-shirt yeah that's true I feel
like gonna go show off your right to
bear arm okay welcome here in the
America done well done sir
alright portrayed playing telling you
I'm sorry I know I know you do
alright so this game is just played
we're trying to knock you're trying to
knock the ball that way
yeah yeah and then you just use these
two things to get with your pull see
like that so these the sticks the two
sticks is all you need the two sticks
the one the left one moves you and the
right one moves your I am crazy there
you go yep yep I think you can't kill me
yeah yeah you could kill me but nice
wait did you ever play any sports in
your life a paperboy or I was a paperboy
you were paper would that's a sport yeah
Oh Oh father I think I should tell you
this I always say Oh father is that's my
sir that's your swear that's my servers
why why is that yours are you just
trying to be a better person
no it's just you know my father would
always sort of say oh you killed you
better believe I because I'm close to
winning yeah we're playing best out of
three dude or best out of five well
you're gonna need to win two more yes
this is real no but no I get it your way
that's part of it too
all right there's nothing generous about
that bear it's gold
yeah there's no goals and pole-vault all
right I think we have a couple fan
questions are you ready ready for level
two which is playing the game and
answering fan questions all right if you
hit him with a fan we're just on the
show today it's it's weird to kill
somebody with Nepal you soon at
Hampshire hello
Kalpa hello Jesus goodness
so Conan O'Brien is my um Johnny Carson
I mean that really is a that's amazing
that's this I was in Yogi Bear 3 do
that's a double travel
you piece of I don't like it yeah yeah
never held a controller for one really
good um no I mean Conan O'Brien is like
do you you've just got to watch the ball
man
that's pole vaulting you've only killed
me with your feet which is something
that I also used to know I really I
think oh no no Brian is like my Johnny
Carson you know yeah it's it was such a
it's such a pleasure to even be welcomed
on the show and I didn't know no their
mother nope [ __ ]
no your mother father I can't kal-el I'm
doing a complete wrong way
hello oh my god alright well that first
game TJ Miller game 1 TJ but we're not
sure I don't win mine
well no do you want to play best best of
5 we can but I just kicked your eye I
would like to try to redeem myself I
know I never lose 3 to 0
alright doing a play different go play
don't play this game alright yo alright
alright so uh yeah I mean Conan O'Brien
has always been my Johnny Carson and
it's just so insane I'm gonna stick with
generous mother um you know sort of be
welcome to the show and to have them
actually Andy is like one of the
quickest improvisers it's ever been
absolutely and and so it's just been
such a pleasure and this is my third
time on this is the only show this is
the only show that's ever been I mean
they let me try and eat two Italian beef
sandwich what is that about
now we're like holding one another it's
amazing you know what this is only legal
in Vermont like a lot of Dreams coming
true right now stay off of it yep now
helman woof you know I love get the
sandwich thing amazing yeah and so you
know I they let me do something that was
just insane where I tried to eat -
Italian B touches in this is like all
conversation yeah well playing video
game like so so Sarah and I are getting
yeah and you know and my uncle Sarah
Sarah is actually I am literally going
against I'm just pull vaulting to my
goal you mother
there you go you mother father I'm
coming back to you I'm coming back I'm
telling you I just really terrible
things to you seem to get that angle
going no yeah sometimes I just jump for
the hell of it just for this smell I
know but I yeah I actually my
grandmother died while I was playing
Street Fighter 2 what yeah that's not
true yeah yeah I was unable to look up
from the game so she died and I never
saw her no that was it her last words
were right you can she was just like oh
you know why yup that's it I got my I
got I got it now I got the I got the
distance alright another fan question
right yeah Scott Philpott wants to know
you were awesome in Cloverfield if there
was a sequel how do you think it would
play out
I would certainly die again or I
wouldn't be in it yes I guys have seen
transformers you'll sort of know that I
I die in a lot of movies then think of
how did you die in transformers I was
burned to Chris boiler alert I was burnt
to Chris
burn to a crisp yeah buddy
emesis uh yeah that's what it's about
ever stirred of that hey you know it's
nerd you ever knew or never snare
detects means not or something I heard
not a word no service oh good job pole
vaulter Oh like a oh my God look at this
no you can't yeah oh that was amazing
can't whoa how could you move time over
now that's yeah wait wait I women oh
well done literally said bones race win
it's like you've won just by playing
just more games read that like you know
what you're great cuz you're really
trying do you want to try this other
game quickly I can't believe you know I
sent you a second time Jesus are you a
gamer yeah I pride myself on being but
now you're making me question everything
there is about myself don't do that
Who am I what am I doing here gonna be a
Republican in 20 minutes hey I have a
question for ya now I like I would love
I would love if there is a Cloverfield
well and then I went the opposite
direction I don't love if there was a
Cloverfield - amazing but I don't think
it's gonna happen
amazing I already rented a bus for that
like to take people to is that true when
you
Oh for transformers yeah yeah fortunes
you know hah - Brad yeah I owe you
mother
sneaking up you mother it's gonna be the
great Wow
come from oh yes I got a po boy
he bears come-from-behind victory
see I'm doing there's a sex joke come
from a giant hole no wow this really has
changed you oh now what happens the true
this is the true me oh look at me just
comment it yeah I wish I could really
hurt you more it's funny video games are
like our only way to to play out
aggression no it's what I and largely
because of my purple shorts how could I
keep this away this is crazy I think you
in case you give up on the whole lack a
super buddy I already gave up
I have a question about your amazing
facial hair already for this I have a
question why you just died at this
answer because I'm terrible there we go
there we go second point ever is that
you or is that people on the show wanted
you to do that that was me and my judge
and I had a great a weird conversation
where I was like oh you must and then oh
nothing just like that's how I fell in
high school it's not working there's got
to be a different way I'm trapped going
the opposite way over here um wait so
what was your question
Oh Mike judging you had an interesting
country sort of you know we argued over
the facial hair and I kind of said you
know would it be would it be okay if I
did this weird and what I'm where I am
right now is called a conquistador okay
and I said well you know can I do a
really weird facial hair and he was like
well you know they're all the only
mutton chops that was a weird like
sexual / you're like this what do you
think they can we be getting is you're
just swell and I else you trust a
three-point goal I can't get it and also
this is just not based on any sort of
real-life anything you know it's you
know it's more real than this the trees
in the woods you're pixelated no return
you got most kills though but there we
go as you know and pole-vaulting yeah
and so what
they all have mutton John and I saw I
was in his movie extract yeah and and in
that one he said well I don't imagine
like he's like a tattooed black hair
ponytail
and I said well I really want to work
with you I can become that yeah I'm not
a very good actor but I'm good changing
my period so I said you know and I
shaved half my hair off on this side
dyed it black jet-black got fake
piercings tattoos don't think yeah
and so even he was like okay now you can
mean the movie and then in this one is
well I imagine kind of like a you know
Penn for Penn & Teller Oh sting long
hair and weird facial hair and I said I
can do that for you and so we argued he
said well I think it's muttonchops and
then like a mustache that connects and I
was like what if it's so much such it
connects and then it's got a weird
goatee back and forth if I said yeah
that sounds good and so now I'm doing a
different thing and I asked my wife I go
what are you cuz River it's funny on the
show yeah yeah it's funny when we're
shooting yes but then I still alive so
this was a little more regal if I did
the conquistador with the mutton chops
right but I asked the showrunner ago
well if you guys thought about it
spatially or around the girls yeah we
don't write that in the script so you
say did you lose three oh I lost three I
lost you want to play one other quick
game and then we'll come in my heart I
know you're about to lose a fifth time
all right if you want this is it you
know what maybe yes maybe I can see they
got a wall you know what that is that's
always everyone is losing is always like
oh this is for the winners but yeah this
I know you've won a thirty of them but
did you double or nothing
all right do we have another fan
question for mr. Miller yes
there better be that would be amazing
now it's it's tough it's like inside the
same as Cloverfield where oh my god you
got but you design the thing you think
it murder your happiness enveloped I do
have a developing terrible gaping ass so
you know I think you know they wanted to
do one they really did but I just I
don't think you can one-up that it
really was the pinnacle of my career as
parking in general that was kind of a it
was like a weird like crotch hit and so
where you chose this I actually thought
against the interns I was pretty good at
this yeah well they're intern well [ __ ]
pain for anybody no I you know I think
it's my deaths are getting worse no I do
III did sort of I did so no please
please man I did sort of do my best work
in Yogi Berra 3d well and pole vaulters
sports brag if they ever make a movie of
super pole vaulters you were a shoeing
shooting if I have the red fascia layer
generous that I gonna have a fedora or
if I'm you I just need to cover my face
and fear you know I think they wanted to
do it but it's hard to do something when
you weren't in the greatest talking bear
comedy that's ever been yeah [ __ ] you
know Seth MacFarlane said to me well tad
made more money all this stuff and I
Spit not in his face but his wife's face
he's not married I like performing the
ceremony
spit in her face they got two waters
it's amazing when she was really took
along to work definitely worth it but
you know so what's the point of making a
second one yeah and you know Michael Bay
I guess and Spielberg were talking about
if I maybe I'll come back for the next
Transformers like as a transformer and I
just I feel like there's a part of it
where Bay is like you know I'd love to
kill him again
even worse no I mean you know I would
love to make a yogi bear three d-21b
it's just a Datsun yeah I would do that
but I am you know I just feel very
fortunate for all the films that I've
done well Yogi Berra 3d and the rest of
them it's just well it looks like
somebody puked on board
yeah just puke just barf barf puke all
right I'm surprised that I made a career
as I look like a toddler it took a
growth serum I would somehow America is
like yo you can be are just I'm very
pleased about it I love it like people
say I look like this is true it looked
like a guy who's like hey you wanna
smoke weed and you're like yeah and I'm
like cool you got any and for me I feel
like the legalization of marijuana or
the green rash as we call it since I'm
from Colorado 3o through my until I die
Colorado will make eighty eight billion
dollars in tax revenue in the next and
marijuana like tobacco in the early days
of America is their only possible
economic weapon against our enemies
so yeah easy peasy pole vaulters too
eyes that are higher like where they
play sports and they're like buddy
sports friends yeah
wait do they both wear shorts that imply
they're more than yes sports friends
yeah sports
yes all right well TJ you can come see
TJ and big hero 6 which opens November 7
thing yeah and follow him at not TJ
Miller
yeah Silicon Valley on HBO absolutely
and then How to Train Your Dragon 3
yeah and now please come see my stand-up
comedy routine yes it's mostly funny
faces and weird noises but there are
very few people that do them as well
that's right and you perform regularly
at the Pleasure Chest yeah I read about
a biweekly show bi-weekly show and every
every other week at The Pleasure Chest
in Hollywood please come check it out
and then I'm all over the United States
TJ Miller does not have a website calm a
Twitter
I'm not TJ Miller you're really trying
to dissuade people from I don't like
people to be just as puke Barbie calm
backslash TJ Miller it's not on Facebook
I will tell you this is an absurdist
and as a fan of Conan and a really
grateful person for being on my Johnny
Carson yeah I know more about giraffes
than any of you boom in your face TJ
Miller everybody awesome thank you for
watching see to for more great video
game play sports brain fart bag
you